[Music]
you guys have a sort of an ingenious
setup you live in the house on the show
your characters live in a house you
actually decided to live in that house
to save money is that right yeah we were
convinced we were gonna get cancelled
yeah yeah once we came up with it as
tight butthole as our slogan for like
this is going one season right yeah we
actually lived in that house before when
we were scouting we were like we're
gonna get canceled we have to we have to
save money and so we continued living
there it's just it's a pigsty those
believe a picture from oh that's from
the show that's actually or that's
before that's before you cleaned it up
yeah that's we cleaned it up for the
show
okay now when you lived in that house
you don't live there anymore is that
right no no we've moved yeah okay but
when you did live there fans of the show
could find out where that house was go
to it knock on the door and you'd be
living there yeah it would blow some
minds so it was just uh what's up man
what's cool is a lot of fries drugs I'm
not you know I keep outing myself but a
lot of people just like do you want to
smoke and a lot of like hey you know I
shouldn't it's a yeah okay it's so
strange for the characters to the people
playing the characters to actually live
in the home who lives there now if you
moved out is it is it now owned by
responsible human beings oh no no no no
no it's kind of turned into this weird
like flophouse where anybody can well
within the family or friends good right
don't go there yeah my younger brother
lives there my best buddy lives there
from high school but there's these you
don't want to live there or even visit I
wouldn't recommend now is there's just
giant human rats yeah yeah I'm like a
three just a giant human rat well I look
like a new book that's invisible and
when you live amongst the rats long
enough it's almost like you become a rat
we went through it we really I never
lived there thank God yeah you have a
girl that loves him yeah so he didn't
have to go down that path so you who you
who you lived with rats
how bad was it uh there was a one like
24-hour period that we killed something
like 18 rats yeah we call it the night
of many many kills Blake found me just
shirtless with a bottle of Windex and a
broom yeah and I killed four rats that
way just come at me Peter I'm right here
and I'll do it again let's say they wear
a coat made of brass what were you
drinking the Windex yeah well thanks
dude yeah you see I mean you you spray
them in the eyes and then they go blind
then you hit them with I don't want to
yeah it's a find that out you could see
anything on you - it's like vinegar
anything Eloise you know home tip on
HGTV here's dinner play the rats on the
eyes Windex yeah no but I hit him with a
broom cause I think Martha Stewart got
to this one here's what you do squeeze
in the eye and then bang yeah it was
weird that it got so normal that they'd
come out and see me doing this and I'm
like what's up Adam just gettin some
milk and I'm like okay yeah a plastic
bag kind of swing it and bang everyone
hates me now but if you were living
amongst them you would know what I was
going you could hear them in the walls
it was that that's nicer than the like
the sticky traps where they're just like
face gets stuck to it then they can't
breathe and they're crying for their
friends I disagree I think you asked any
rat he'll take the sticky trap on an
overhead wire
oh you don't appeal it to the head you
don't speak for rats have you opened oh
no I trust me I know what the rats want
open the traps of those things and they
have like the day counts Cratchit yeah
that's the nice thing is they sticky
traps always come with a little journal
yeah engage my team still no Windex put
me out of my misery